สวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะครูบีสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนค่ะสวัสดีนักเรียนทุกๆคน
เช่นกันค่ะค่ะแล้วก็ขอต้อนรับนักเรียนทุก
คนนะคะเข้าสู่ห้องเรียนภาษาไทยห้องเรียน
comprehensible ไยค่ะใช่ค่ะนะวันนี้ก็มา
เจอครูบีแล้วก็ครูปุ๊กอีกแล้วนะคะอ่าเรา
มาเจอกันวันนี้น่ะวันอะไรครูปุ๊กวันนี้
เนี่ยวันอังคารค่ะวันอังคารวันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะครูบีวันที่ 10 นะคะค่ะเดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
ตุลาคมค่ะค่ะเดือนตุลาคมเนี่ยเป็นเดือน
ที่เท่าไหร่คะเป็นเดือนที่ 10 ค่ะค่ะปี
พ.ศหรือพุทธศักราชที่เท่าไหร่คะ
2506  66 ค่ะเป็นปีคริสตศักราชที่เท่า
ไหร่คะ
2023 ค่ะอ่าก็วันนี้ครูปุ๊กครูบีก็มาเจอ
กับทุกคนนะคะในวันอังคารที่ 10 เดือน
ตุลาคมนะคะปีพุทธศักราช
2566 ปีคริสตศักราช
2023 ค่ะอืนะเพราะว่าครูบดีเนี่ยไม่เจอ
ครูปุ๊กเนี่ยมาหลายอาทิตย์เลยนะเกือบจะ 1
เดือนแล้วมั้งคะโอ้โหไม่รู้ครูบีไปไหนค่ะ
แล้วก็วันนี้เนี่ยตอนที่เราอัดกันเนี่ย
โอ้โห 13:00 นแล้วครูบีเเนี่ยกินอะไรหรือ
ยังคะ
อืตอนเช้าเนี่ย 800 นเนี่ยกินแล้วค่ะกิน
ข้าวเช้าแต่ตอนเที่ยนเนี่ยยังไม่กินเลย
ค่ะครูปุ๊กรู้สึกหิวค่ะเพราะว่าตอนนี้
13:00 น 13:00 น 0 นแล้วนะค่ะใช่ค่ะครู
บียังไม่กินข้าวหรอแล้วครูบีมีอะไรกิน
หรือยังยังไม่มีเลยค่ะครูปุ๊กเพราะว่าตอน
เนี้ยครูบีรู้สึกเบื่อกับข้าวค่ะเบื่อต้ม
ยำกุ้ง
ออไม่ไม่ไม่ใช่กครูปุ๊กเพราะว่าตอนนี้
ใกล้ๆที่ครูบีอยู่ใกล้ๆอพาร์ตเมนต์ครูบีเ
เนี่ยมีร้านอาหารส่วนมากเนี่ยเป็นร้าน
ร้านอาหารตามสั่งค่ะออผัดกระเพราไก่ไข่
ดาวอย่างเงี้ยค่ะครูปุ๊กนะเพราะว่าร้าน
อาหารตามสั่งเนี่ยก็ต้องสั่งเนาะเวลาอยาก
กินอะไรอยากกินไข่เจียวหมูสับก็ต้องบอก
ต้องสั่งเนาะนะไม่มีอาหารที่เาทำทำแล้วก็
ใส่ไว้หรอคะครูบีไม่มีค่ะต้องรอค่ะอ่า
อย่างถ้าครูบีอยากกินอ่าผัดกะเพราเนี่ค่ะ
กครูปุ๊ก
อืโอ้โหหน้า
อร่อยอร่อยค่ะแต่กินทุกวันก็เบื่อค่ะ
เพราะว่าร้านอาหารส่วนมากเนี่ยจะมี
ไก่มีหมูมีกุ้ง
ออกินทุกวันก็เบื่อไม่มีอย่างอื่นเลยค่ะ
ครูปุ๊กไม่มีผัดกะเพราปลาไม่มีไม่มีค่ะ
เค้าไม่นิยมทำเพราะว่าผัดกระเพราปลาเนี่ย
มันต้องเอาปลาเนี่ยไปชุบแป้งแล้วก็ทอด
ก่อนโอมันยากใช่ม
ใชใช่นะมันเหมือนเทมปุระไงต้องเอาไปชุบ
แป้งแล้วไปทอดไม่อย่างงั้นเนื้อปลาเนี่ย
มันก็จะเละออกไปเนาะนะแล้วก็นี่ค่ะครูบี
มาค่ะมาบ้านครูปุ๊ก
อ้าแถวบ้านครูปุ๊กเนี่ยมีอาหารให้เลือก
กินเยอะเหรอคะเอ้าก็ครูบีเเนี่ยไม่อยอยาก
กินหมูไม่อยากกินไก่ไม่อยากกินกุ้งไม่
อยากกินปลาหมึกอืพาดีก็ต้องกินปลาค่ะแถว
บ้านครูปุ๊กเนี่ยมีปลาทอดนะมีน้ำมันเยอะๆ
นะแล้วก็รอร้อนๆเหมือนทอดเฟรนช์ฟรายอ่ะ
ค่ะนะพอน้ำมันร้อนๆเนี่ยเขาก็เอาปลาเนี่ย
ใส่ลงไปชู้โอ้โหแล้วปลาเนี่ยตัวใหญ่ค่ะ
ครูบีอือร่อยมากกินตอนร้อนๆเนี่ยโอ้โหโอห
สุดยอดค่ะอนะหรือว่าถ้าครูบีบอกโอ้น้ำมัน
เดี๋ยวอ้วนอ่ากลัวอ้วนก็กินปลาเผาค่ะนะ
บาร์บีคิวเลยอันนี้ชอบค่ะครูปุ๊กครูบี
เนี่ยชอบกินปลาเผามากๆแถวบ้านครูปุ๊กก็มี
ขายเหรอคะปลาเผามีค่ะมีค่ะนะก็ถ้าครูบีเ
เนี่ยชอบกินปลาเนี่ยก็ต้องมาค่ะแถวบ้าน
ครูกุ๊กมีค่ะใกล้ๆนี่นี่เองเออแต่ครูบีคะ
ครูบีเเนี่ยชอบกินปลาเนี่ยชอบกินส่วนไหน
ของปลาคะ
โอ
จิง
อื้อหือปลาบ้านครูปุ๊กเน่ากินจริงๆน่าจะ
อร่อยมากนะคะเพราะว่าเนื้อหายไปหมดแล้ว
ยังไม่หมดค่ะเหลืออีกนิด
นึงอันนี้เนี่ยเเลยเข้าไปค่ะอถ้าถามว่า
ครูบีชอบกินส่วนไหนของปลาก็ต้องดูก่อนค่ะ
ครูปุ๊กปลาเนี่ยมันมีอะไรเยอะแยะเลยเนี่ย
ในรูปเนี่ยก็มันก็ต้องมีหัวแน่นอนค่ะส่วน
ของหัวปลาอืใช่นะหัวปลาเนี่ยมันก็จะมี
ทั้งตาทั้งปากนะแล้วก็มีนะเหงือกปลาค่ะ
เหงือกเวลาหายใจเเอาออกซิเจนไปทางเหงือก
เนี่ยคะนะอันนี้ก็จะเป็นส่วนของหัวปลานะ
อืแล้วก็นะถ้าเราดูตรงส่วนนี้เนข้างหลัง
เนี่ยนะก็จะเป็นส่วนของหาง
ปลาใช่มยแล้วก็อันเนี้ยครูปุ๊กเนี่ยแล่
เนื้อเอาออกไปแล้วค่ะอืก็เลยเห็นก้างอ
ก้างปลาเห็นมั้ยไม่เรียกกระดูกนะนะถ้าคน
ถ้าไก่ถ้าหมูเป็นกระดูกอันเนี้ยอ่าอันนี้
เป็นก้างปลาอันนี้ก็จะเป็นครีบของปลาใช่
มยนะแต่ว่าครูพุ๊กเนี่ยชอบกินเนื้อก็เลย
เอาเนื้อออกไปค่ะชึบนี่ค่ะ
ออปลาใช่มั้
อ่าแต่ว่า
โอ้โหถ้าเป็นเมื่อก่อนเนี่ยคุณปุ๊กเนี่ย
คุณย่าเนี่ยชอบตรงพุงปลามากๆเลยค่ะนะตรง
พุงปลาเนี่ยคุณย่าบอกว่ายิ่งแบบฝนตกแบบเ
นะโอ้โหปลาเนี่ยมันอร่อยโอ้ครูบีก็เคยได้
ยินนะหลายๆคนเนี่ยชอบกินตรงที่เป็นพุงของ
ปลาใช่มั้ยเนี่ยแหละครูปุ๊คิดว่าประเทศ
ไทยเนี่ยมีคนกินตรงส่วนเนี้ยเนาะพุงปลา
เนี่ยหัวปลาเนี่ยนะแต่ว่าต่างประเทศเนี่ย
ฝรั่งเนี่ยอาจจะไม่ค่อยกินเนาะอืมใช่ค่ะ
เราจะเห็นแต่นักเรียนเนี่ยจะกินแต่เนื้อ
เนื้อของปลาเนาะนะแล้วก็ทำออกมาเนี่ยเป็น
เนื้ออย่างเดียวเลยเนี่ยนะแต่บางคนเนี่ย
จะชอบมากต้มยำหัวปลาอืนะคะต้มยำพุงปลา
เออโอ้นะบางคนบอกโอ๊ยหางปลาก็อร่อย
อืครูบีอ่ะครูบีชอบตรง
ไหนครูบีเเนี่ยชอบกินหางปลาค่ะครูปุ๊กอโอ
ครูบีชอบกินหางปลาเหรอคะทำไมอ่ะไม่เห็นจะ
มีเนื้อเลยอ้าตรงหางปลาเนี่ยมันมีเนื้อ
นิดหน่อยแต่มันอร่อยนะครูปุ๊กแล้วก็ตอน
เด็กๆเนี่ยผู้ใหญ่ก็ชอบบอกว่าถ้ากินตรง
หางปลาเนี่ยจะว่ายน้ำเก่งค่ะอ๋ออจะได้
เป็นเหมือน little  mermaid
เนาะแล้วครูบีเเนี่ยกินแล้วเนี่ยว่ายน้ำ
เก่งมั้ยออตอนนี้ยังว่ายน้ำไม่ได้เลย
ค่ะแต่ครูบีชอบนะครูบีรู้สึกว่าตรงหางปลา
เนี่ยสำหรับครูบีเวลาครูบีกินเนี่ยเออมัน
อร่อยไงครูปุ๊ก
อืเพราะว่ามันมีเนื้อนิดหน่อยใช่มเราก็จะ
ได้แบบ
อื้อหืออืแบบ
ดีค่ะครูบีไปกินข้าวกินปลากับครูปุ๊กได้
ทำไมคะอ้าแล้วครูปุ๊กชอบกินส่วนไหนของปลา
คะครูปุ๊กชอบกินเนื้อปลาค่ะ
นะไม่ชอบกินหัวปลาไม่ชอบกินหางปลาไม่ชอบ
กินพุงปลานะครูปุ๊กเนี่ยชอบกินเนื้อปลา
ค่ะนะครูบีดีมาครูปุ๊กครูบีไม่ชอบกินส่วน
ที่เป็นเนื้อปลาเลยโอ้อันนี้ค่ะเราโอเค
ค่ะไปด้วยกันแล้วก็เวลาจ่ายเงินเนี่ย 50%
นะคะ 50% จ่ายเท่ากันค่ะครูบีเออดีมยครู
ปุ๊กเราไปกินปลาเผต้มยำปลาเนี่ยเราไปกิน
ด้วยกันได้เนาะได้ค่ะเพราะว่าครูบีก็จะมี
ส่วนที่ครูบีชอบนะหางปลาครูบีชอบหัวปลา
ด้วยมยหัวปลาเนี่ยครูบีไม่ชอบค่ะ
อืนะพุงปลาล่ะคะพุงปลาก็ไม่ชอบกินชอบกิน
หางปลาโอ้ดีมากเลยค่ะเพราะว่าตอนเนี้ยมี
โอโหมีคนเนี่ยชอบกินเนี่ยนะพุงปลามากๆ
เนาะในสมัยก่อนนี้ยิ่งชอบกันมากเลย
นะคุณย่าคุณปุ๊กเนี่ยอย่างชอบเลยปรุงปลา
หัวปลาเนี่ยไม่กินเนื้อเหมือนกันค่ะเออนะ
เอ้ยพอคิดถึงเรื่องชอบกินปลาเนี่ยครูปุ๊ก
เนี่ยมีนิทานเรื่องนึงนะไม่รู้ว่าครูบีเ
เนี่ยเคยฟัง
มยนิทานนิทานเกี่ยวกับอะไรอ่ะกครูปุ๊กอ
ไม่ใช่ซินเดอเรลล่าไม่ใช่สโนวไวท์นะเป็น
นิทานไทยเกลี่ยวเอ่อเกี่ยวกับนะเป็น
เพื่อนกันค่ะตาอินกับตานานะเพราะเราจะ
เรียกคนที่เค้าแก่ๆเนาะเป็นผู้ชายเนี่ยก็
จะเรียกว่าตาเหมือนๆนะเหมือนๆเป็นพ่อของ
แม่เราอ่ะนะก็อายุมากแล้วใช่มั้ยเราก็จะ
เรียกตาอเพราะว่าบางทีเนี่ยเราเห็นผู้ชาย
ที่อายุ 60  70  80 ปีขึ้นไปเนี่ยคืออายุ
มากแล้วเราก็ไม่รู้ชื่ออะไรเราอาจจะเรียก
ตาแต่ถ้าเรารู้จักอ๋อชื่อตาอินก็เรียกตา
อินชื่อตานาก็เรียกตานาใช่ก็คนนี้ชื่ออิน
คนนี้ชื่อนาก็เรียกเขาว่าเอาตาเข้าไปค่ะ
ไม่ใช่ตาเรานะไม่ใช่ตาที่เรามองเห็นนะคุณ
ตาเนี่ยหมายถึงว่าพ่อของคุณแม่ก็อาจจะ
เป็นเพราะว่าเขาแก่แล้วเนาะก็เหมือนกับคน
ที่อายุมากแก่หรือยังคะโอหแก่แก่แล้วค่ะ
หนวดสีขาวแล้วค่ะอืออโชคดีครูปุ๊กไม่มี
หนวดสีขาวอ่ะถ้าถ้าครูปุ๊กผมสีขาวเนี่ยก็
จะเป็นยายปุ๊กอ่าถ้าครูบีผมสีขาวก็จะเป็น
ยายบีเอออ่าครูปุ๊กก็เลยเอาเคมีใส่ให้หมด
ค่ะเปลี่ยนเป็นสีดำใช่มั้กลัวใช่กลัวคน
เรียกยายแต่ว่าผู้ชายก็จะเป็นคุณตาเนาะ
แล้วก็เรื่องเรื่องเนี้ยครูบีเคยฟังมั้ย
โหครูปุ๊กเคยสิคะแต่ว่า
นานนานมาแล้วค่ะตอนครูบีเเนี่ยเด็กๆอายุ 5
ขวบเพราะว่าคุณคุณตานี่แหละค่ะเล่านิทาน
ให้ฟังแต่ครูบีจำไม่ค่อยได้แล้วค่ะครู
ปุ๊กมันนานมากแล้วโอ้โหนี่ค่ะครูปุ๊ก
เนี่ยไปซื้อหนังสือมาหนังสือดีมากเลย
เพราะว่าเค้าวาดรูปได้สวยค่ะค่ะอืมนะถ้า
นักเรียนดูนะรูปเนี่ยดูดิโนะพอเห็นรูป
เนี่ยเราคิดถึงคนไทยสมัยก่อนเลยเนาะบ้าน
คนไทยแล้วก็บ้านคนไทยนี่ก็จะมี
คลองมีเรือ
อออืขนมนปู
ปุ๊กเห็นมั้ยเราเดินทางเนี่ยพายเรือใช่
มั้ยสมัยก่อนใช่นะทุกบ้านที่อยู่ติดคลอง
ก็จะมีเรือค่ะแต่ว่าเป็นเรือเล็กหรือว่า
เรือใหญ่ก็แล้วแต่เนาะนะถ้าเราจะเอาของไป
ขายต่างจังหวัดเนี่ยก็ต้องนอนในเรือเพราะ
ฉะนั้นเรือก็ต้องมีหลังคาข้างบนมีหลังคาอ
นะแสดงว่าอันเนี้ยเหมือนตอนนี้ก็อยู่ชนบท
หรือว่าบ้านนอกเลยเนาะอืนั่นน่ะสิเพราะ
ว่าตาอินกับตานาเนี่ยครูปุ๊กให้ดูรูป
เนี่ยเหมือนกำลังไปทุ่งนาแล้วก็มีสระน้ำ
โอ้แล้วตาที่ถืออะไรอยู่เนี่ยคะครูปุ๊ก
ชื่อตาอะไรมั้ตาอยู่เอไม่ใช่ตาตาอินตาอัน
นี้ตาอินเนี่ยครูบีรู้ค่ะเค้ามีอุปกรณ์
จับปลาค่ะครูปุ๊กอื้อหืออันนี้เรียกว่า
อะไรคะครูบีนี่เรียกว่าแหค่ะอือไม่ใช่แห
อือไม่
ใช่ไม่ใช่ค่ะแห
แหอ่าแฮๆแฮๆแห
นะก็มีแหแล้วก็มีอันนี้เ้าเรียกว่าภาษา
ภาคกลางเนาะตะข่องอืมตะข่องค่ะเป็นคล้อง
สำหรับเวลาเราจับปลาเราก็เอาปลาเนี่ยใส่
ไว้ในข้องนะคะใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าข้างข้างบน
เนี่ยมันจะมีฝาปิดลงไปเนาะแต่ฝาเนี้ยไม่
มีแบบไม่ไม่ใช่ครอบลงไปมันจะเป็นเหมือน
ไม้แหลมๆถ้าปลาจะออกออกไม่ได้ค่ะเจ็บอืนะ
ทีนี้เนี่ยตาอินกับตานาเนี่ยเค้าเป็น
เพื่อนกันค่ะนะเป็นเพื่อนกันแล้วก็เป็น
เพื่อนรักโอโหเพื่อนรักก็แปลว่ารู้จักกัน
มานานเป็นเพื่อนรักกันใช่ค่ะแล้วก็หลายๆ
ครั้งเนี่ยก็คือเค้าเนี่ยจะพึ่งพาอาศัย
ซึ่งกันและกันหมายถึงว่าเค้าเนี่ยจะเป็น
เพื่อนที่แบบช่วยกันนะเพราะว่าอ๋อช่วย
เหลือกันใช่ตาอินเนี่ยจับปลาเก่งโอนะจริง
ๆแล้วตานาเนี่ยภายเรือเก่งโอโอก็ดีนะครู
ปุ๊กเป็นเพื่อนกันตาอินจับปลาเก่งตานาพาย
เรือก็เก่งอันเนี้ยก็ไปด้วยกันก็ได้ช่วย
กันอืใช่ค่ะแล้วทุกวันเนี่ยเพราะว่าเวลา
ไปจับปลาเนี่ยมันต้องไป 2 คนเนาะครูบีคน
นึงพายเรืออีกคนนึงก็หว่านแหเราบอกหวานแห
อืมนะ
เอาแล้วก็ช่วยกันใช่มยแต่ทีนี้เนี่ย 2 คน
เนี่ยพอไปด้วยกันเนี่ยทุกวันเนี่ยไปด้วย
กันก็จับปลามาพอปลาได้เยอะก็แบ่งกันนะอ่ะ
คนละ 1 ตัวคนละ 1 ตัวแบ่งกันแบ่งกันแบ่ง
เท่าๆกันนะก็แบ่งกันก็ไม่มีปัญหาอะไรเนาะ
จนมาวันนึงเนี่ย
โอ้โหวันนี้เนี่ยจับปลาก็ไม่ได้นะไม่มี
ปลาอืเออจับไม่ได้ปุ๊บบางทีเวลาเราไปหา
ปลาไปจับปลาเนี่ยบางวันก็ได้ได้ปลาเยอะ
บางวันก็ได้ปลานิดหน่อยบางวันไปจับปลาก็
ไม่ได้ปลาสักตัวก็มีนะคะอใช่ค่ะไม่รู้ว่า
ทำไมเนาะก็ไปไปก็ไปที่แบบที่ตัวเองอ่ะรู้
ว่าเออที่เมีปลาเป็นประจำแล้วก็ไปนะไภ
เรือไปนะแล้วก็วันนี้เนี่ยไม่มีปลานะแล้ว
2 คนเนี่ยก็คุยกันเนาแล้วก็วันวันนี้ไม่
มีปลาอืพออีกวันนึง
นะอยู่ๆตานาเนี่ยนะตานาเนี่ยก็วิ่งมาค่ะ
มาบอกตาอินตาอินอะไรตานามีอะไรเรเร็ๆแก
ข้าน่ะเห็นปลานะตัวใหญ่ที่ไหนที่ไหนเห็น
ที่ไหนเอาแหมาก่อนเอาแหมาโอเคเอาแหมาก่อน
เออไปเร็วอ่าแล้วก็ตาตานาก็พาตาอินเนี่ย
ไปหานี่ๆๆตรงเนี้ยตรงนี้แหละนะมีนะตรงนี้
แหละที่ปลาตัวใหญ่เนี่ยมันอยู่อืก็แปลว่า
ตานาเนี่ยมองเห็นปลาเนี่ยมันอออเห็นมั้ย
เห็นมยนี่เห็นมยคะนี่แล้วบอกเแปลว่าปลา
ตัวใหญ่อ่ะครูปุ๊กใช่ค่ะมันมาฮุบอากาศใช่
มยฮุบออืมันก็จะเกิดเป็นเห็นมยเป็นวงเลย
อ่าก็ต้องรีบให้ตาอินเนี่ยเมื่อวานแหค่ะ
เห็นมยก็ชี้บอกเลยนี่ๆๆนี่อยู่ตรงนี้เห็น
มยคนเเห็นมยตานาก็ชี้ชี้ลงไปที่น้ำนี่ๆๆๆ
อยู่ตรงนี้อยู่ตรงนี้นะแกเร็วเร็วๆเร็วๆ
เร็วๆเสียงดังไม่ได้เนาะเดี๋ยวปลาได้ยิน
ใช่แล้วตาอินเนี่ยก็วิ่งถือแหมาเลยนะอื
แล้วก็หว่านแหเลยค่ะโอ้โหเป็นยังไงคะีคะ
อันนี้เนี่ยเวลาหว่านแหแล้วแหเนี่ยมัน
กระจายออกมากว้างว้างใหญ่ๆแบบเนี้ยยอมรับ
ได้เลยค่ะว่าตาอินเนี่ยหว่านแหเก่งจริงๆ
อ๋อบางทีแวะหว่านไปมันไม่มันไม่ไม่บาน
เหรอคะครูบีบางคนเนี่ย
โอ้โหแข็งแรงมากนะพอเหวี่ยงแล้วก็หว่าน
แห้ออกไปเนี่ย
ชิ้วมันๆมันไม่ไม่บานออกอย่างงี้นะคครู
บุ๊กมันเป็นอย่างเงี้ยค่ะอืมนะแหเนี่ย
เห็นมั้ยนักเรียนมันมันบานออกใหญ่ๆเนาะนะ
ก็เลยนะตาอินเนี่ยอ้ไม่ใช่ตาอินทำไมชอบ
ตาอิน
ออใช่ตาอินเนาะใช่ตาอินเเนี่ยนะก็หว่านลง
ไปค่ะนะเหวี่ยงแหลงไปดูสิคะอือาการนี้
คือดีใจอดีใจอ้าเแนสเตอร์ยูไนเต็ดชนะ
ลิเวอร์พูลอันนี้เนี่ยตาอินใช่มั้ยจับปลา
ตานาโอ้โหดูแอคชั่นนี่โอโหยิ้มกว้างมาก
อ่ะตานานี่เป็นกองเชียร์ค่ะเอ่าเหมือนเรา
ดูฟุตบอลเห็นมั้ยครูปุ๊กอ่าเวลาเราดู
ฟุตบอลเนี่ยเวลาโอ้โหทีมที่เราเชียร์
เนี่ยยิงประตูปึ้งเราจะโอ๊ดีใจเหมือน
ตะอินเลยเห็นมยจับาได้อเห็นมั้ยหว่านแหไป
แล้วพอร่วบแหเข้ามาเนี่ยมีปลาตัวใหญ่ค่ะ
นะแล้วก็ 2 คนก็เลยดีใจกระโดดกันใหญ่เลย
เห็นมั้ยเท้าไม่ติดพื้นเลยกระโดด
เลยดีใจมากเพราะว่าปลาตัวใหญ่ไงคะครูปุ๊ก
แล้วตาอินก็หวานเก่งเนาะออใช่ค่ะแต่ค่ะ
ปัญหามันเกิดค่ะ
เอ้าจะมีปัญหาอะไรคะเพราะว่าตาอินเนี่ย
หว่านแหได้ปลาตัวใหญ่ก็จบ 2 คนก็ดีใจก็
น่าจะโอ้โหมีความสุขใช่มยเอ้าๆๆทำนี้มี
ความสุขมยคะเมื่อกี้ยังเย้ดีใจอยู่เลยอ่ะ
ตอนนี้เนี่ยถึงเวลาต้องแบ่งปลาค่ะเพราะ
ว่าจับมาเนี่ยได้แค่ตัวเดียวแต่ตัวใหญ่อื
เมื่อก่อนเนี่ยจับตัวเล็กๆนะก็แบ่งกันใช่
มก็ไม่มีปัญหาไม่มีปัญหาค่ะแล้วก็ลักตัว
แต่ในรูปนี้ครูปุ๊กน่าจะมีปัญหาเพราะว่า
ตาอินกับตานาเนี่ยจับทั้งหัวตัวเองจับ
ทั้งหัวปลานะคะน่านี่ไงเค้าตกลงกันไม่ได้
ค่ะไม่เหมือนครูปุ๊กครูบีนะครูบีชอบกิน
หางครูปุ๊กโอเคครูปุ๊กไม่ชอบเอาไปเลยครู
ปุ๊กชอบกินเนื้อปลานะครูบีไม่ชอบกินเนื้อ
ปลาอันนี้โอเคนะ
ได้ไม่มีปัญหากันออใช่แต่อย่างที่ครูปุ๊ก
บอกว่าคนสมัยก่อนเนี่ยเขาจะชอบกินพุงปลลา
ค่ะอืนะเขาก็อยากได้ตรงส่วนของหัวแล้วก็
พุงใช่มยเขาก็จะแบ่งแบบนี้
อ่าแต่ทั้ง 2 คนอยากได้ส่วนที่เป็นหัว
อ้าตาอินกับตานชอบกินส่วนที่เป็นหัวปลา
เหมือนกันอย่างงี้หรอคะใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าหัว
เนี่ยเวลาแบ่งแล้วจะได้พุงไปด้วยอนะพุง
เนี่ยมันจะมันๆมันเหมือนมีไขมันนะชอบ
คอเลสเตอรอล
มั้งจริงๆแล้วเนี่ยคนไทยมีเยอะมากนะชอบ
กินหัวปลาพุงปลาปุ๊กไม่เห็นหรอมีร้าน
อาหารใหญ่มากต้มยำหัวปลาครูบีก็คิดอ๋อต้ม
ยำเยมีแต่หัวปลาใช่มั้ยไม่มีเนื้อ
ปลามันจะมีเนื้อปลานิดหน่อยค่ะเออเออแล้ว
ก็ตาอินกับตานาเนี่ยแย่งหัวปลาเหรอคะครู
ปุ๊กใช่ค่ะเห็นมั้ยต่างคนต่างจับหัวปลาอื
จะเอาหัวปลาอย่างเดียวนะก็แย่งทะเลาะกัน
ค่ะทีนี้เนี่ยทะเลาะกันไปทะเลาะกันมาฉัน
จะเอาหัวปลาแกจะเอาแกก็เอาหางไปสิอนชอบ
กินหางปลาอยากได้หัวปลาก็ทะเลาะกันใช่
มั้ยใช่แล้วก็บอกว่าฉันเนี่ยเป็นคนทอดแห
นะหว่านแหฉันก็ต้องได้ส่วนที่ฉันอยากได้
สิอ้าวตาอินก็บอกว่าตาอินเนี่ยเป็นคนเห็น
ปลาแล้วก็บอกให้เอ่อตานาเนี่ยเห็นปลาแล้ว
ตาอินเเนี่ยเมื่อวานถ้าตานาไม่บอกก็ไม่
ได้ปลานะอืมใช่ตานาก็เถียงใช่มั้ยว่า
เนี่ยได้ปลาก็เพราะว่าฉันเนี่ยแหละเป็นคน
ไปบอกให้มาจับอืนะตาอินก็บอกแต่ถ้าฉัน
เป็นคนจับเนี่ยฉันจับไม่ได้ล่ะแกก็ไม่ได้
กินใช่มั้ยอือนะ 2 คนก็ทะเลาะเถียงกันว่า
ใครควรจะได้หัวใครควรจะได้หางปลานะแล้วก็
ทะเลาะกันตีกันทะเลาะกันนะจนเสียงดังมาก
ก็มีคนที่ที่อยู่ใกล้ๆค่ะเขาชื่อตาอยู่
ค่ะโอ้โหดูเป็นมาเฟียเลยนะเนี่ยเห็นมั้ตา
อยู่เนี่ยคือได้ยินเสียงตาอินกับตานา
ทะเลาะกันเออก็เลยมาดูเหรอคะใช่ค่ะได้ยิน
เสียงทะเลาะกันแล้วก็เลยมาอ้าวเกิดอะไร
ขึ้นนะตาอินกับตานาก็ฟ้องบอกว่าเนี่ยฉัน
เนี่ยไปบอกให้มาจับปลาอืนะตะอินเนี่ยก็มา
จับพอได้ปลาเนี่ยตาอินก็จะเอาส่วนที่เป็น
หัวแล้วก็พุงฉันก็อยากได้ส่วนที่เป็นหัว
แล้วก็พุงนะอ่า 2 คนเนี่ยก็ให้เหตุผลใช่
มยตอยู่ก็เลยบอกเออไม่เป็นไรฉันจัดการให้
ออเดี๋ยวจะเคลียร์ปัญหาใช่นะก็เลยให้คน
นึงเนี่ยจับหัวปลาอีกคนนึงเนี่ยจับหางปลา
เอาไว้จะได้แบ่งให้อืมออตาอยู่เนี่ยถือ
มีดอืตาอินกับตานาเนี่ย 1 คนก็จับหัวปลา
อีกคนก็จับหางปลาตาอยู่เนี่ยมีมีดเดี๋ยว
จะแบ่งให้เท่าๆกันอใช่ค่ะนะสุดท้ายเนี่ย
ตาอยู่เนี่ยก็ปันชบชบอ่าก็แบ่งหัวปลา
หางปลาออกไปส่วนตรงกลางตาอยู่ก็เอาไปเลย
ค่ะเอ้าแล้วตาอินกับตานาก็โอเคใช่มั้ยไม่
โอเคแต่ 2 คนเนี่ยกำลังตกใจว่าเฮ้ยอะไรต
อยู่วิ่งหนีเลยค่ะเห็น
มั้ยแหมแต่อยู่นี่ไอคิวดีนะคะเออแบ่งปลา
ให้หางกับหัวตัวเองได้เนื้อปลาแล้วก็วิ่ง
กลับบ้านไปเลยอืใช่วิ่งหนีไปเลย 2 คน
เนี่ยเพื่อนกันเนี่ยก็มานั่งแบบ
โหไม่น่าทะเลาะกันเลยใช่มั้ยอืใช่ถ้าแบ่ง
กันแค่ 50% มันก็ยังได้เยอะใช่มยตอนนี้
เนี่ยส่วนที่เยอะที่สุดเนี่ยตายอยู่เอาไป
ค่ะนะเพราะว่านักเรียนดู
นะอ่ะดูในรูปเนี่ยที่หางปลาเนี่ยก็มี
เนื้อปลานิดหน่อยตรงหัวปลาก็มีเนื้อนิด
หน่อยอืแต่ส่วนที่เป็นเนื้อปลาเนี่ยตะ
อยู่เอาไปเนี่ยมันเยอะมากเห็นมั้ยคะ
โอ้ไปอยู่ก็เลยยิ้มกว้างเลยเห็นมอืเห็นม
เป็นเพื่อนกันเนี่ยเนาะถ้าคุยกันยยอมเสีย
เปรียบนิดหน่อยก็โอเคนะแบบให้อีกคนนึงได้
เยอะกว่าก็ไม่เป็นไรนะหรือไม่ก็อาจจะแบ่ง
แบบตรงกลางเลยนะอืนะก็จะมีปัญหาอีกก้าง
ใครจะได้บางคนก็ชอบดูดก้างก้างปลาใช่มั้ย
อืถ้าแบ่งนักเรียนบอกทำไมไม่แบ่งหัวไปหาง
คนละซีกซ้ายกับขวาครูบีมีวิธีค่ะอ่าถ้า
ครูบีเป็นตาอินกับตานาครูบีก็จะแบ่งอย่าง
เงี้ค่ะอืมันก็จะมีปัญหาอีกว่า 2 คนก็
อยากได้ก้างปลาไปด้วยใช่มฝั่งที่มีกล้าง
ปลาก็อาจจะแบบมันได้เยอะกว่าไงอืมันแบ่ง
ยากอีกเพราะว่าปลาเนี่ยถ้าเราแบ่งครึ่ง
แบบเนี้ยมันแบ่งยากเนาะแต่ถ้าเราแบ่งแบบ
50% เนี่ยเออมันจะง่ายกว่าใช่มอย่างงี้
ใช่โอ้โหเอถ้าแบ่งกับครูปุ๊กไม่มีปัญหาหา
ค่ะเอาส่วนหัวหรอค่ะเอาไปเลยค่ะนะเอาส่วน
หางมาให้กุ๊กุกก็ได้แต่ว่าต้องมีเนื้อนะ
คะอือนะแต่ก็อย่างว่าเนาะแปลว่าตาอินกับ
ตานาเนี่ยชอบกินตรงพุงปลากับหัวปลามากๆนะ
ใช่ค่ะเนาะโอโหไม่มีใครอยากได้ก้างปลา
ครีบปลา
นะเหงือกปลาค่ะออกซิเจนเยอะ
นะเอออันนั้นต้องเอาไปทอดไงเออถึงจะกิน
ได้ทั้งหมดใช่มั้ยแต่ถ้าเอาไปต้มยำเนี่ย
มันมันก็จะอร่อยไงปุ๊กมันได้ดูดตรงที่
เป็นหัวปลาพุงปลาใช่มั้ยอ่าหลายๆคนก็ก็
เลยชอบนะคะ
อืนะโอเคั้นงั้นวันนี้เนี่ยเราหมดเวลา
แล้วเราต้องลาทุกคนไปก่อนนะคะค่ะขอบคุณ
มากค่ะค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ